I asked him before he died I said what
do you want to come back as and he goes
well I'm a pilot honey so I I'd like to
be a bird of flight and then he said or
cannibal chipmunk and I was like we're
gonna let that be the morphine
and uh and then I went home and it was
during covid so I didn't I was around a
lot of people so I was nervous to be
around my kids so I quarantined away
from them and I had the both doors open
where I was staying and I was doing this
sort of tapping meditation thing that I
do and
I heard a commotion and I looked on the
dining room table there was a hawk and
it was staring at me
and I was like oh my God
dad
and he flew out onto the banister and
turned around and looked at me and
turned his head sideways and off he went
every time I walk out of my house this
[__] Hawk follows me all the way
anywhere I'm going until I get where I'm
going and then he flies away
so I'm a Believer